now also tonight twice failed
presidential candidate hillary clinton
is letting us know that she's not going
anywhere and she isn't getting out of
the game of politics anytime soon take a
look
i believe you said it's up to us to make
sure the plot stays fictional after
writing this any interest at all in
getting back into the game of politics i
will never be out of the game of
politics i'm not going to be running for
anything but i really feel amy and i
know
george was interviewing adam schiff
before
i really feel like our democracy is at
stake
well there you go but unfortunately for
hillary americans are moving on and see
her is just another political punchline
as she refuses to take responsibility
for her failures and blames everyone
else all while she aimlessly searches
for relevance and maybe a chardonnay in
the in the forest and a reason to be in
the spotlight so here now for reaction
fox news contributor leo terrell who'll
have absolutely no opinion about any of
this along with former acting director
of national intelligence rick grinnell
uh gentlemen thank you very much uh well
let's let's start with uh matt's uh uh
uh
uh report out of california rick uh you
know i moved to new york from california
going right from the pan into the fire
uh and california we love california
it's a great state uh but we're looking
at like let's the toy isle as an example
we've been talking about distractions to
some degree tonight that the democrats
continue to want to distract people
california is on fire it's a dumpster
fire and he wants to talk about what you
can have in a toy aisle what's that all
about
well i thought it was very uh troubling
to see that if this is such a serious
problem why is it that only
businesses that are more than 500 people
impacted if this is a real serious
problem shouldn't everybody be included
in this toy aisle look i i have a big
problem like everybody in california
that our governor is trying to dictate
marketing campaigns to
stores why is he involved here why is
the sacramento media allowing him to get
involved in these issues we've got water
problems we've got energy problems we
don't have a lng terminal on the west
coast at all we're not participating in
the explosion of liquid natural gas
because our governor is literally
worried about toy aisles you can't make
this stuff up and yet this is this is
happening i i just want to say it's
shameful that the media in sacramento
are allowing him to get away with this
well that's a very good point and it's
to your point about why is it just the
larger box stores it also doesn't apply
to clothing
so i i'm not sure it's like if you're
worried about a kid's impression about
what they can and cannot wear you know
when i was growing up leo i was like the
marble champion at school uh i you know
was wearing pants i was not going to
wear a dress i didn't like barbies i i
had my remember the hot wheels track
yeah that was my thing um and it was
like i like being a girl i like being a
girl right now but leo it really comes
down into training people to believe
that the government knows better than
you that you as a parent or as an
influencer with young children are
useless and bad and that it's the
government who has to tell you what to
do about that uh what is your take on
that
well you just summed it up tammy and
rick is absolutely correct there should
be a lawsuit on this whole uh toy story
because it changes it gives a
preferential treatment for one set of
stores and not the other it's unfair and
it also implies that the parents don't
know what's best for the kid it
basically insults the parent the
government knows better than the parents
in the decision making it's insulting
but this is a guy who just fought back a
recall so he's basically on a war path
and he's going to try to more more and
more government control which means less
and less freedom for people in
california it's terrible here in
california you know and only the
democrats you were smart to leave a demo
the democrats would start a war using
barbie you know that would be typical
for them right uh you know at the same
time there's another law and i have to
admit there is a long time ago we had
these fights about uh the leaf blowers
in california the sound it was just
everywhere you know we with the sound
here in new york uh giuliani got rid of
some of the sound that's all back
because this it ruins the quality of
life but here once again you've got a
dynamic where
he's talking about lawn mowers but in
san francisco you're walking over
human feces
needles
people sleeping on the street
it's the crime i'm surprised you know
you can go into any toy isle and find
toys in an aisle or any products because
of the shoplifting that is allowed uh
is there a reason why he's going after
the lawnmowers rick is there any reason
why this kind of an issue is is a factor
or is it just another distraction
they're allowed in sacramento
politicians are allowed to sit around
and think of crazy ideas of of how to be
more progressive so how do we help the
environment even more and they're just
they're getting away with it and and
that's the whole troubling part you know
we've got a lot of parents who are
really upset about the schools yeah and
we've got you know people who are upset
about the high gas prices uh we're
conserving water like you can't believe
we're told to have brown uh grass it
it's out of control he's not paying
attention to any of the real issues you
know and leo i have to say as we close
this out we're looking at they really
cared about kids they would have opened
those public schools right instead of
just letting the private schools operate
keeping kids out of schools you know
mask mandates in that regard and we're
supposed to believe that they're the
compassionate one because they're going
to dictate you know what your child is
going to look at in a and rick i i we've
been speaking thinking are you going to
put like trucks right next to the
barbies and think our kids are going to
be confused leo is there any way out of
this other than getting rid of gavin
newsom
uh no we need we need to do fix
california now which is rick's
organization and the problem is this
when you talk about the kids that's dear
to my heart because i'll tell you right
now education is the key to break the
poverty cycle this state is union run we
don't have any school choice we don't
have a a situation here where we can
basically take over the state as long as
these democrats are in charge we need to
have a two-party state in california
right now it is deep deep blue tammy
well you know i think that what
californians need and both of you are a
very good example of this is some good
rhetoric and representation that reminds
people about that it can be different
and that there is a future because all
of this is radicalizing parents i think
in general certainly the school board
stuff is but when they're telling you
about what toothbrush you can buy for
your kid that of course steps over a
line gentlemen thank you more hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else